i guess like another question i have for
you which is like a conversation i've
had with
a lot of people who have never been to
asia who had like never been to asia or
like lived in asia
is this concept of cooking your own meal
in a restaurant like going to a korean
barbecue or going to a shabu-shabu
and having to like cook your own meal
and like
cook your own meats like what was what
was your
what's your opinion of that as a
colonial white manager
korean barbecue was with you and i was
like i'm just let god do this
let the brown boy do it because i
really like the social aspect of one
being able to control
like how for example how cooked your
steak is and being able to do that
yourself like yeah sure we have
we have gordon ramsay right yeah he's a
white man who can cook that's an anomaly
right why people can't cook man i i'll
i'll give it to
every other culture because there's
because there's a chain of pubs in
australia
where inside of the pub there's
literally just a butcher
yeah of just rows and rows of steaks and
meats and whatever
yeah and you pick out whatever steak you
want you pay for it they give to you and
then you have to take that over to the
barbecue
and just make it yourself the reason why
i don't like cooking it myself
is one uh i want to pay the other person
to do that right yeah
like i i don't want to pay you so i can
[ __ ] up this piece of me right yeah i'll
go and do that at home yeah
like i'll
because the worst part is is when you
like go to korean barbecue you take
someone there when you take someone to
korean barbecue or any kind of barbecue
like that
you're the one who has to cook yeah
because you took them there yeah it's on
you
and they just sit back and they're like
go ahead go ahead and then i'm like
[ __ ] dude how do i know this is cooked
and the worst part is
they're like let's get chicken i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
when is chicken cooked i don't know
because i i'm personally
i will just let the chicken get black
and i'm like all right it's safe
to go with safety
it's just like you're okay with going to
a barbecue and having someone cook for
you
yeah so why why can't you put that in
like a restaurant experience right
what's the difference yeah i mean
because it's like we're all bringing our
own meat
you know we're all uh breaking just
order like good quality meat i guess
why would i do that at a restaurant when
i just do that at home are you the exact
same experience
why did you go to a barbecue why do
people do barbecues because it's with
your friends yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
the exact same thing with that
that's exactly the same thing with like
going to a shabu-shabu or going to like
a career but
if i could okay if you gave me the
choice you're like connor you can have
korean bbq where you cook it
or korean bbq where the the guy who
works here and and often comes
on like because they they see you
[ __ ] burning the meat anyway and they
they come in like no no let me
they start like they're like they come
and fix it for you so just just save the
embarrassment and just do it
right but it's just like an activity
right because i feel like it's like
don't do an activity
why are you gonna make your [ __ ] meal
into an adventure bro because
because like okay here's the thing
especially like when
i remember going to america where the
only reason you
like especially hang out with sydney's
family like deep in the midwest
like they only go to a restaurant to eat
yeah and that's that's just i think
that's how it should be
but the only exception to me is hot pot
because you can't [ __ ] hot butter
you can't [ __ ] that you just throw
everything in just just throw it all in
i don't know
i've seen people [ __ ] up a whole lot
yeah that's true that's true you can
[ __ ] up a hockey but like to me like a
restaurant can be like an entire
experience
where you like catch up with friends and
everything but like i feel like in the
west
you like you don't go to a restaurant
for any anything else but the purpose of
just
having a meal and eating i disagree i
think it's it's changing a little bit
now at least it was in the uk before i
left like it was very much becoming like
a
an experienced kind of thing over a you
know whatever the restaurant has been
like some of the
quietest restaurants i've ever been to
have been in america
yeah where no one is talking and they're
just silently eating i'm like you could
i mean you could do this at home i don't
like to make my meal
that i look forward to all day into a
stressful thing
like if every time i took a [ __ ] i had
to put in like the input code and it's
flashing on the bidet
dude that's gonna i don't wanna yeah
it's a fun activity at first but that's
gonna get old real [ __ ] fast
like if you're adding steps that's the
same thing i mean i just feel like
you're adding steps to something that
doesn't require steps right but it does
that's where the enjoyment comes in
yeah it's like a great it's like a group
activity right okay shout out to the
people who get anxiety with cooking like
i'm sure you can relate you're like why
would i want to [ __ ] this up
in my defense like i can't cook to save
my life like i i
i [ __ ] up a toast right like that's the
kind of like that's the kind of like
[ __ ] and you and you will cook your
own food in those restaurants and yet
i love going to yakiniku and being the
one to be like i'll cook the meat yeah
because it's the one and only time i'm
in front of food where i have control
like it's like a power move it is a
power let me [ __ ] have yes
let me show you how it's done yeah i
mean it's like if you get impressed by
someone putting meat on a grill i mean
fair play to you man i'm not really
buying that like i'm
i'm like don't work in the kitchen
that's what i love about like yakiniku
and like korean korean uh korean
barbecues is that
it's literally you just have a [ __ ]
meal i've just grilled me
yeah that's like having the burger
without the vanish
this is my main problem cut out the
[ __ ] meal man and just give me the
good [ __ ]
i love yakiniku don't get me wrong man
yeah i love yakiniku
there is a fundamental problem with
yakiniku go on
i hate the weight the loading times for
the meat
because you can't skip the loading time
you can't skip the load
right okay when okay at a good
restaurant right
what would a good restaurant do they
they prepare all the food so it comes
out at the same time yeah
sound of a good restaurant right because
everyone can start eating immediately
right with the yakiniku place right
especially if you go with [ __ ] meleen
right i i want to chuck all the meat on
straight away yeah so
we can start eating everything yeah and
like we have a constant stream of meat
coming in
right meline when i went with her she
wanted to put one tiny [ __ ] piece of
beef on it and wait
five minutes well that's maelyn's
problem yeah yeah you know
but that's why you don't go to a
restaurant with me like what i'm saying
no because what i like to eat i want to
keep eating
yeah that that's why you got to [ __ ]
optimize it so you have you have
you've got yours you can [ __ ]
optimize this because you have you have
like the meats on it
and then as the meat's getting done you
put more meat on it and you put this on
the side
and then as you're eating the meat then
the other meat
is cooking there's always there's never
there's never like a down period no no
that's not true that doesn't happen
real in a realistic world can't that
doesn't happen that is how that is how
it happened i don't know because you've
just not
you've just not optimized your career
because you've just been to [ __ ] yeah
and then also also right
here's another awkward scenario i hate
this right okay
four of you go to yakiniku restaurant
right right the a5 beef comes out yeah
it's in six pieces
what do you do gone who get who gets how
who who decides who gets how many a5
this is the a5 beef gun come on this is
like 8 000 yen for these six slabs
who gets what gone because personally
i'm not gonna lie i want to
okay well that that that i argue that
just goes down to the asian experience
of
sharing your meals and sharing your like
dishes right why do we turn six in the
in the eight card
because someone someone one of them in
half no that's depressing that's
depressing bro you can't do that man
it's already it's already pre-connected
and asian families can do it no problem
i need to do monopoly mind games at my
[ __ ] family let me tell you how to
make sure i'm getting the most
let me tell you how to solve this let's
go because this happens every time yeah
you have the four pieces
you have the two pieces left and the
connor's like
somebody's gonna eat these okay i'll
just take it in my mind right
that is the experience hanging out with
connor my mind's right he is that guy
who's just like listen
you know what's more stressful than when
you're hungry and there's one piece left
and nobody seems to give a [ __ ] that
there's one piece left on the table it's
like
are we gonna eat this or not because if
no one's gonna do it i'm gonna do it
then just do it
no because i also you know maybe okay
with you guys i don't give a [ __ ]
right yeah but maybe when we first get
to know each other i didn't want you
guys to go home and be like why is khan
always [ __ ] taking all our food man
he's always going for it straight away
he's going for the kill right this is a
real social problem
because if i'm if i'm getting dinner
right every single time
i have my piece i'll chat a little bit
and i look to go and get my next piece
and the [ __ ] fat ass over there is
taking it every time i want to know that
there's at least a cool down period
between him eating one piece
and like there's at least a two minute
cooldown to wait right this is so
stressful
there's so many social issues with me
being cooked on its own
just let us all order ourselves you're
like way too over complicated in this
manner
because you don't realize it joey you're
creating problems no no no because joey
your social skills are like perfectly
normal human beings right right
you just glide through it you don't
worry about it joey just dances through
it yeah for me
it's like a science bro it's a science
to social situations right
you've got to make sure you don't do
anything for a new person that could
make you seem weird
right all right so that includes not
eating too much if you go home then you
think you're a fat ass oh get a load of
this guy right eating all our meat right
that we all split the bill on yeah yeah
the most connor should have paid yeah
but in my in my mind it's like if you're
not going to eat it we
like you guys know we're splitting this
yeah so if you're not going to eat it
i'm going to just [ __ ] take it but
sometimes that hasn't been made clear
right who's
who's splitting are we spreading this
are we not like we don't know these are
the awkward social situations that you
encounter
often right but i'm just like well you
know this is the
this opportunity of taking this last
piece of meat is here
right now i don't give a [ __ ] about like
oh
what percentage are we going to split
this basement how many pieces of meat
i'm jealous of you jerry that you can
throw caution to the wind like that and
just take the meat if people think i'm a
fat
ass well then that's their problem i
have the full stomach not you i mean
you miss the opportunity i take that
opportunity i am an opportunist
in that sense you say that like you're
the one who always takes the last piece
when it's me
yeah it is here it's me in my head i'm
just like look at this
what i do is i wait you gotta wait right
until everyone
you're pretty confident that everyone
has just decided they don't want this
anymore right right and then you go in
for the kill
see i've been in way too many situations
where it's such a japanese thing
especially when you go to like a
business dinner in japan
there's always it's like a rule it's
like a social rule to leave
one piece of what the [ __ ] it is that's
so annoying because
because it's this whole idea of like
japanese coaching you're making a
stressful situation no you go yeah no
you go it's like
you go it's it's the crowd before me
that it's the whole collective mentality
right yeah
and so i've been in so many of those
situations where in the end
no one takes the pizza and they just
take the food back and then they just
take the food back oh no dude
take me back to the kitchen give me all
the one piece my favorite that's right
now
because i've been in so many situations
where i'm like why is he taking that
away there's still one piece left on it
yeah i just i'm just like
let me use my gaijin card for a second
here just like give me that piece think
about all the wasted food that happened
because of socially awkward situations
yeah
wasn't it better if we all just like
figured out a system it's just a piece
of meat bro it's not just a piece of
meat
that's a5 beef you're trying to she
meant something to me
i mean if it's a5b fair enough but if
it's like
if it's like another piece of like pork
or something i'm like [ __ ] nice
this guy is so [ __ ] this guy fighting
words this guy
gets two million subs he changes man no
more